YouTube as good of a clip as I've ever
had about loving what you do on a daily
basis I this was a big one
d-roc and I are completely convinced
this is gonna be one of the most viewed
videos we've ever had so what to tell
you this process patience it means
you're not it means you're not absorbing
patience it's it's there though that's
the thing you're aware of it I'm aware
now you got to connect to it you gotta
ask why though my biggest thing is why
are you worried about other people
because that's where it's coming from my
process of going in and how the finish
line is going to look to other people a
hundred percent like literally that guy
just repeated we're fronting 50 times
already for you every song like like
like fronting is a mistake you're
letting other people's judgment matter
helen mir-21 dude do you know how [ __ ]
on I got a twenty one I worked in my
daddy's liquor store making seven bucks
an hour
I'm sittin on myself though cuz it's
like a little virus I know you're
[ __ ] on yourself because you're not
[ __ ] on yourself you're letting your
homie or your aunt or somebody else [ __ ]
on you it's going in your head and now
you think you're [ __ ] on yourself
bro you're letting other people's this
is very complicated but unbelievably
simple you're worried about what other
people think I get the support though
some people get the love that's good but
it just gets conflicted so what do you
want to happen I don't know you gotta
figure out what makes you happy on your
turn I realize oh that's okay though
that's that's I think your dwelling and
putting more compounded pressure on
yourself for something that every 21
year old is living you don't be 21 year
olds no
just said at least be a goal like
something from happy because [ __ ]
sneakers men the facts so you can have
your shoes on to love for the race kind
of that's cool that's fine
but I'm telling you make it the process
of life not some sort of goal even the
Jets things affront I want to try to buy
the Jets what it really means is I love
the process so much that I want to do
something so big
really so I could do the process [ __ ]
buying the Jets I want the [ __ ]
process of trying it you gotta fall in
love with doing something every day not
what the [ __ ] are gonna get you or what
the goal is that arbitrary [ __ ] up there
is [ __ ] you up I'm so being serious
yeah just what do you like to do do it
and put an eat on it and if that's being
an artist and you can only eat like a
[ __ ] McDonald's every day then you're
good you got to fall in love with the
tick you got to get to that place and
not like be not judge it so hard when it
didn't feel great
my god you're judging it right you're
judging yourself and south you're
[ __ ] Judge Judy on your life get out
of it I don't judge myself for [ __ ] you
don't like it it didn't go well today
[ __ ] you
I say [ __ ] you to all you cuz I say [ __ ]
you to myself I don't judge myself you
know why because everybody else has to
everybody else sucks dude they just
might be [ __ ] faking it better than
you please leave a real comment of what
struck you in this video hope you
enjoyed it
[Music]
you